this week's episode of ear biscuits is
brought to you by Squarespace the
all-in-one platform that makes it fast
and easy to create your own professional
website or online portfolio I'm into
professional websites I'm not into
amateur websites I used to be all about
amateur websites but then I started
realizing that they weren't effective
and I have moved up to professional
websites it's not even possible to
create an amateur website at Squarespace
no it's not it is all professional even
even when it's amateur it's professional
even if what you do and what you're
advertising or displaying on your online
portfolio or website is amateur it'll
look professional that's just kind of
how it works you can try it out for free
without even entering your credit card
information and once you're convinced
that the site is great you can make sure
you get 10% off by using the offer code
are a and the L that's Randall that's
like rhett and Link get it are aandl but
Rhett is really tough to spell it's open
to interpretation so that was link we
just came up with the code our Andy will
use a seeing link all the time for
reasons I'm not aware of squarespace.com
offer code R and L now it's time for a
near biscuit welcome to air biscuits
I'm link and I'm Rhett it's time for
another conversation with someone
interesting from the internet this week
we have Chester C we talked to him about
his journey from Disney Channel host to
shirtless bartender we also get into his
love life from living through the
rejection of his first crush to crying
on stage at VidCon in the aftermath of
his breakup with Taryn southern another
youtuber I mean it kind of gets gossipy
a little bit talk about trial we try to
find out who his new crush is because
this person does exist so yeah this is
this is a gossipy episode of of ear
biscuits and you may know you know
Chester is he's definitely got a
reputation for being a ladies man and
the thing he's known most for is music
and to be just to have a fair
clarification there as a ladies man in
terms of being a performer not like not
like hey we as friends
Chester C privately this dudes known as
the ladies man no I mean you know I mean
I'm not saying a player I'm saying that
you know he's a guy who writes songs
right ladies yeah and you know it's
interesting because you know we're
musicians we write comedy songs he's a
musician he writes mostly original love
songs very heartfelt love songs I mean
just like the performance at VidCon
it was incredibly heartfelt well it made
me think it unlocked a memory of mine
and that was shook it loose yeah it was
that I was like you know I thought to
myself you know I've never written a
love song before then I was like oh I
have written a love song I wrote a love
song to my wife what right after we got
married like we're like very early you
know what no no we know we were engaged
I wrote a song about her and I will tell
you that this is something that I do not
know about you know people talk about
but it is a question well what's
something that you guys don't know about
each other well this is what it is this
because I'm the last person you want to
tell this to because it is embarrassing
you would not come to work the next day
or come on yes it is why haven't you
told me okay well first of all cuts cut
pay man I wrote a love song to my wife
would you like to hear okay okay hold on
never told me but to sit to just say
that that is by default embarrassing
that that shows a gross misunderstanding
of love and music man I mean I'm a
comedic songwriter and so it's not
typical but it's not embarrassing I'm
not saying you're embarrassed right now
talking about it I'm saying that there's
a reason you did you you kept this
information from me this no the reason I
kept information from you is because I
kept the information for myself I told
you that it was a memory that was lodged
in my brain that she shook loose why did
you bury it no well because the because
the performance of the song which I'm
going to tell you about in a second is
embarrassing in itself the song the fact
that you know I had just
fallen in love with my wife and I was a
musician and I can play guitar and write
a song and sing it all those things made
sense and I still think they make sense
and you know what I wish honestly and
I'm sure my wife would agree with this I
wish that again in the in the past of 12
and a half years of merit I would have
heard another one maybe you know maybe
you think that it really begs the
question why the owner should write one
you should maybe you should write a
little song here well I'll write them
all the time yeah I just don't tell you
about him because it's embarrassed okay
so I wrote a song and I you know I
honestly do not remember anything about
the song except the chord progression it
was I had my think it was a D a D
fingering and then like I played some
different things with my pinkie and kind
of ran down through this like quit this
D chord and it was just kind of funky
so basically Tom Petty's free-falling no
but it was a different a different
little progression there but I wrote
this song for and you know she loved it
of course you know as a young girl no it
wasn't rosemary to me and so I performed
this song for her and she loved it and I
did I don't know why this just this is
the embarrassing part either I I know
this is my idea I told her family her
family her mom and her dad and her
sister okay you told him no I told him I
wanted to perform the song I wanted them
to listen to me because what to her with
them there oh man now this my face is
getting a little red right now because
because this is you know me and this is
another thing I'm so embarrassed for you
I can't believe that you would do this
this is not the kind of thing that I'm
so glad I wasn't there because I avoid
embarrassment like the plague why would
you say why would you do that because I
was young I was in love you were married
right no you were dating you had to have
been dating you know no man who's
already married his wife was
been engaged I don't know I need to talk
to my wife about the specific you were
trying to get engaged is what it must
have been well it worked you know well
marry for a dozen years that's a good
time to children with this lady I mean I
worked I hope that you were trying to
get engaged
we need to redeem this man this is it's
about to get more embarrassing miss Yeah
right okay
so can't believe this this is gonna
surprise a lot of people who listen
because everybody thinks you know
because you know in as I am being
entertaining and you know trying to be
funny and you know I don't I don't have
a I don't have the reputation as a
sensitive person right and I'm not
really sensitive in the traditional
sense of the word but when it comes to
things like a lot of people wouldn't if
most of the mythical beasts out there
had to guess who would cry more in a
movie they would probably pick you right
in fact is is I would I cry like a baby
at movies and I never seen you cry at a
movie and I've watched look lots of you
making this about me no but I'm just
saying that like there's there are
certain things that there are certain
things that I was really sensitive about
I perform this song for my wife's family
and I started crying I swear to you I
cannot be your friend nice I stood but
first of all I think this is winning a
lot of new fans out there just between
me and you yeah this you know I'm not
making I'm not making this man don't
show your hand don't tell him you're
winning fans and you're making this up
I'm not making it up
so I begin to weep not now not not like
open weeping having to stop performing
but well I wept a little bit man and but
first of all I mean it totally sealed
the deal I mean my in-laws oh now you
know you're sure no my in-laws it was my
sister-in-law was like you've got to
marry this guy a second ago you didn't
even remember if it was before you
married or not it did because now you're
trying to redeem it no it's because I'm
very selfless it must just be because I
I just it was so much about my whole
life it was honestly I don't know why
don't remember it well
but I do remember it's one of the things
that you think about and you're like I
mean first of all I'm kind of old we're
old if you haven't noticed and I've been
married for over a decade there's a lot
of memories we my wife and I talked
about the early stages of a relationship
she's like do you remember that I'm like
no I don't I'm sorry but this is one of
those things it was kind of like a dream
and then when we started talking about
Chester and what he does he looks Lodge
the dislodges crazy
what other kind of embarrassing things I
wonder that I can might dislodge during
doing this ear biscuits this is like
therapy for you huh yeah I think it was
I think you gained a glimpse into what
it's like to be Chester see yeah that's
what it was
so let's get to our conversation with
the one and only Chester see and we've
already mentioned that this guy sings a
lot of songs on the internet and one has
won the hearts of a lot of teen girls
out there he's got over a million
subscribers on his Chester see YouTube
channel he also stars in and produces
awesomeness TVs hit series side effects
and is a co-founder of the premium
content channel yom-yom f and joins
grace Helbig Hannah Hart and mamrie Hart
in the feature film camp Takota here it
is our convo with Chester C so which
part of your name is is made up the last
name C to me is like okay that's that's
too elegant to be real I think it was
with two days ago
grace needed my full name for something
right and she had to double check she
said she texts me is like hey sirs is
less name really C not trying to be done
anything just yeah oh it's the man that
you have on the mug upstairs Lionel I
know yeah
Chester Lionel C look over here look we
got we got all trying the line all right
this mug right okay so hold on this is
big news to us yeah
are you named after Lionel's no named
after my grandpa but what's his name
Lionel yeah yeah I would have given
anything for this all right he's he was
he was already he already left this
world before I was born but he was born
in 1899 that crazy really
he found a world war one world war two
in Korea apparently as a Marine
wow that's a weird world I don't know
anything about grandpa Lionel I wish she
was alive let him quietly
he's like a mythological being yeah you
like this fought in these wars you never
met him your namesake you probably hate
me because if we're not real men anymore
no one's real there's no like real men
you know he comes from the real man era
yeah me confused like you're very
feminine so was his last name see was
this on your dad's side
yes yeah so so for the record see is
real see see it see Israel and yeah did
you ever think about you know going into
an entertainment career that hello
Chester Lionel Chester Lionel I thought
about I thought about a cc no I there's
one of those you know Chester and Lana I
think equally if you're writing a script
and you need to make sure one of the
characters is a nerd you can choose
either one of those names and I think a
Lionel Richie he's inger yeah I don't
want to follow in Lionel's footsteps all
right I want to be I mean you do have
more of an opportunity for originality
other other Chester musicians there's
chester bennington who lead singer
Linkin Park okay
but yeah the cool thing about Chester or
Lila I could have done this I could have
Madonna did and yeah just took him take
him in the last name off because it
sneaked enough yeah you could pull that
out you can do with Brad chunk like I'm
just gonna go by bright like I think you
would have to spell it with an A not an
ER so check Chester I like that yeah
yeah that could have worked and it's not
maybe late you can still do that yeah
when I was in middle school I was really
upset
this one kid ate a lot of flamin hot
cheetos and he got the nickname cheeto
and I thought I was so cool but I also
really liked flamin hot cheetos and my
name is Chester and on about
you know I was more deserving of the
nickname and I still think about that Oh
Chester cheeto yeah whatever you want
yeah
okay so let's where we born born in
Northern California
Fairfield it's like pretty much between
San Francisco and Sacramento on i-80 not
the 80 because it's not LA right is this
gonna say the I back home by 40 it's not
the 40 you know we really put some
weight on those freeways out here
there's like a flat desert area or when
you get that far north
well the adjacent cities called vaca
Ville which is cow town Dixon there's a
lot of cows I my best friend had a barn
raising now it's not like that I mean it
wasn't like farms but there were a lot
of farm areas and and your best friend
got his friends over and they built his
barn
his dad yeah so my dad went over and we
all went over and we helped build this
barn
he had a goat ram llamas around yeah
that thing was crazy
in fact they live right next to my
elementary school and I distinctly
remember more than once an announcement
over the PA system that said you know
Elaine or Trevor as his sister you can
you please report to the office your
sheep are on them on the round exactly
the sheep are out again yeah your cow is
running around the field yeah so this is
small-town Northern California yeah it's
not too small I mean it's it's got a
little bit of a population to it but it
but it's you know it's not too big for
there not to be sheep yeah exactly
that's still happening yeah yeah you
have any siblings one older sister okay
she's awesome how much older she's cool
she is for three and a half three now
four years older okay
and your parents they still together
yeah they're doing it they're still
doing the marriage thing they're still
doing it though yeah lame what do they
do what do they do they they uh they I
don't know what they do they they're my
mom's kind of just chilling out relaxing
a little bit my dad's still
works on radar we using the militaries
in the Navy he worked on radar when he
was the military's networks as a
civilian but still for the military okay
yeah they do a lot of that they live out
in Palmdale so I get to see them that oh
they move they move close yeah being a
Navy kid did that mean moving around as
a kid or didn't for me because um he
would end up just having to go on these
you know six months you know tours or he
would be a four at one point he had to
leave for Philadelphia for a couple
years and instead of us moving with him
we actually just kind of made that work
oh um so yeah I'd have to move much but
but yeah and typically a Navy brat
he's usually running around all parts
the world no your mom is Filipino right
is that yeah correct
mhm so what was that like growing up and
uh well we're two two cultures how do
they meet I was up during one of his
military exactly yeah exactly so using
the Philippines stationed over there and
then they met they got married in about
I think they knew each other for three
and a half four months and that's not a
long time now and they they're been
together for what and going uh there I
don't know 36 37 years now 38 years
pretty good yeah pretty good so he
brought her up here what was the what
was it like growing up in that
environment with the was a two different
cultures type of thing or it was I I you
know my mom has become so Americanized
at this point I mean she still has the
that you know the accent I was gonna try
to do a bad Filipino I stopped yourself
yeah impersonate your mom but the nice
thing is because I'm half Filipino I
feel like I have the that's not racist
card when I'd if I if I oh if I stick to
that race yeah
right right away with that but um yeah
but it's bad I'm not good at dude yeah
it just comes off like mrs. Swan or
something it's not even close to a real
accent of any sort okay but yeah I
remember eating a lot of weird foods and
what's it what's the filipino stereotype
I don't know they I think the stereotype
is they like karaoke
they love karaoke okay is that true my
mom likes kid
[Laughter]
I think that I think this is a good
serotype maybe I think the Filipinos
made this one up but they're like
they're really good at dance and really
good at singing but you can't can't have
good stereotype that's not fair right
Filipino made one they're really good at
things self-made stereotypes sir
yeah well good you're more than a half
good singer so oh thanks um yeah I'm
dance I can move I'm more of a mover
yeah I don't know if it's called dance
so your mom didn't teach you to dance
well what was it like growing up what
was the what was the day-to-day
what was it like growing up I don't know
I I'm trying I'm trying to thank you
what did I want to do I wanted to be a
pilot
I wanted cos you know Top Gun so I want
to be a fighter Emma in the Navy that
was probably I think when I go back and
I look at you know what do you want to
be when you grow up and you go to your
childhood you know documents that your
parents keep it's always f-14 fighter
pilot you switch over to fa-18 you know
because the military right you were
informed yeah yeah but and I wanted to
go to Annapolis and I want to do that
only my best buddy dude the barn-raising
he actually did go to Annapolis and he
followed through yeah he followed
through I was like I don't want to do it
anymore I wanna I don't want it so at
what point did that start to shift when
I landed up going to I went to UCLA and
I studied acting when I was there
UCLA he said okay and so I got I fell in
love with the arts and I looked into the
military they didn't have a really good
arts program so it was like a whole lot
of opportunity to act in the military so
what made you want to be an actor to get
into the I I just I fell in love with
acting and just after high school near
the tail in high school I don't know
there's just something fun about being
something else for a bit and but did you
do like the school play thing or no I
was a tennis player in high school okay
yeah that was my thing that my love for
acting had like near the end of high
school and and I got really interested
in it so you were like the jock as much
as a tennis player yeah I don't know if
a tennis player was a job
I definitely was the tie like I was
captain of our team and you were good
I was no weird division to school so I
was good for division to school whenever
that means means not good in any other
Division one school but yeah I did I was
that kid that was you know an hour early
to school every day practicing sirs I
loved tennis tennis was my thing no are
you musical already it was something
that you hadn't playing piano since I
was six okay writing songs since I was
10 so music has always been there it's
always it's always been like a release
for me though my parents never made me I
never I've never had lessons my parents
have never forced me to it never it was
never work for me so for me it's always
been a place to go when I'm stressed so
there was a piano in the house and you
just started please leave me ivories
yeah exactly
and Orton tickling both um you can
twinkle and if you want high you twinkle
um but I was like I pay for my kids to
get lessons maybe what should I be
telling them to teach themselves what
should you tell your kids to teach
themselves yeah because I don't want to
pay for the oh how to teach yourself how
do you do it without having to pay for
the lessons I mean how did you do that I
don't know I just I was I just kept
hitting them you know what's funny
people it seems it's a lot easier than
people think it really really is yeah I
think of it this way you know you don't
have to think much I assume you can type
yeah yes I'm but I took a class okay to
learn how to type okay but still but
even still like but you get to the point
where your your mind doesn't have to
think about where a is your mm-hmm your
pinky just goes and you can just start
going it's the same thing to an extent
with the piano
it's just sent just translate your mind
thinking of letters and your mind
thinking of sounds so I play by ear so
for me I've got a pretty good grasp of
what those keys are going to sound like
and how I can put them in combination
mm-hmm this is the most up down way of
explaining myself a ten-year-old you
were instinctively kind of just going
with this yeah I'd be like oh wow if you
hit those keys together they make this
sound and you play around you like huh
if you do this that's and you were
writing original songs yeah yeah yeah
cuz I started I having crushes on girls
love song and I was like yeah and I I
remember Brian Adams everything I do I
do for you is my favorite song
used to listen down replay on my tape
player cuz that's what we had and and I
said I want to write someone's like that
I wanna I'm sure that guy gets up look
into my yeah you got it
yeah and that's what it sounds like yeah
yeah over there just are seeing it go
Chester it's so high no that's a high
one that's that I don't wanna screaming
you're right okay so you're right you're
writing songs at age of 10 about other
girls now we just like serenading like
hey baby come over and sit on the piano
because Moses I've been writing and I
still do if you anyone that follows me
knows like majority of my songs are love
songs and that's what always has always
been like really well free but that's I
don't know I like Lionel Richie man lay
the same thing tell us tell us about the
first girl that you remember having a
crush huh the first girl actually I'm
her name the first girl I remember
actually I've been crushing on was this
girl name is Stephanie standing
I just I'm throwing her name out there
Stephanie standing I'm never gonna never
gonna see her here from this billion
that's fifth grade fifth grade he's
listening yeah and and she definitely
didn't like me I remember that well what
was it a try future was she beautiful
for I think she was beautiful one or a
fifth got a cookie bhai say that's right
what you were also an I don't take this
out of context back in those fifth grade
shoes what do you I think she was so
pretty today to be different words yeah
yeah no I'm sure she's still
great-looking today yeah maybe she is
listening I am single that's a good name
though to have a crush so what do you
remember I remember my first crush was
Jennifer Pearson she sucked her thumb in
kindergarten so did he started early and
I was like yeah like we got that in
common I didn't sound that didn't sound
right I see where you yeah not what I
meant by that but we're all thinking it
now though so we might not have thought
of it until you did that yeah yeah she
had a speech impediment because she
sucks her thumb so much turned you on
and I just thought it was really cute
and
remember locking eyes with her one day
at naptime
and you put your thumb in your mouth so
now it's your turn Chester tell me more
about Miss Standen I miss I remember um
you know when you I remember fifth grade
fifth fourth or fifth grade and even
you're that age you think things will
impress girls I still do you're
irrationally or it's not logical to
think these things but I still do you
know I remember thinking if I can want
to do a back handspring she's totally
unlike me you know or if I can win the
turkey trot she's totally like me
I remember those are two are real those
are two real things I'm a call with
specifically to her I don't know did you
learn any other things win the turkey
trot
I didn't I do remember she was standing
you know it took four laps around the
field to do this turkey trot November I
remember him being very cognizant that
she was standing at one area and I would
jog you know the whole piece but then
sprint by when she oh yeah oh yeah even
though didn't really make sense because
I didn't come in or place well so it was
just like that's weird that kind of look
good by Stephanie yeah
never oh I did learn the back handspring
I did learn the back handspring that
didn't do it either no no it was really
confused was she was she going with
somebody else no no and I do remember
you know digging into and trying to find
out if she you know she thinks anything
of me
I was friend yeah I thought I camera
this true and I don't want to make it
seem like she was a mean 5th grader but
I pretty sure she told another friend
that I had a big head hmm
yeah like my body I think I think it is
true I think when I was in fifth grade
my body hadn't I think my head started
like faster than my body
yeah that's cause oh I think she said
something long like when I was running
it looked like I might fall over or
something something like and that they
were in the turkey trot in front of her
probably didn't know
hey I've got I've actually I actually am
crushing on someone right now and it's
all I'll tell you kit well that's that's
unacceptable
okay mmm okay all right well we're gonna
get to that point all right okay so
you're obviously we know that you're
musically gifted we know that that
apparently started at a young age but
then it wasn't hey I'm gonna go off to
some school and major in music or I'm
gonna just bypass school and be a
musician it was I'm gonna go and study
acting
yeah so how did were you thinking oh but
music is always gonna be a part of my
life or like how is that working yeah I
mean that's exactly right I didn't I
didn't know where I would go after
college I knew that I wanted to study
acting III truly I really do appreciate
acting as a craft which is not the case
from I would say most actors now if if
I'm being honest it's a very I have a
different outlook on acting I really do
enjoy it and I knew that I want to study
music I didn't know what I didn't know I
would be an actor or that I would get
involved in acting in the traditional
sense center or even that with music I
wasn't positive what I would do after
college I just knew at that moment I
loved it and I wanted to study so and
then after college I ended up landing a
gig on the Disney Channel and I was a
host for a show called Disney three six
five four three years and and that was
so what kind of show was that the host
it's an interstitial so basically in
between the programming it would come on
and I would interview like Miley Cyrus
or something a Gomez and you know the
High School Musical cast or whatever
eyes so I would go to carpet events it
sound like a Ryan Seacrest II kind of
thing but in the Disney World and I had
to be very very very energetic even
though I was already in my 20s I'd be
clean-shaved
pretend I was fifteen sixteen okay and
talk with a very high voice did did they
tell you this it was like okay this is
who you have to be oh yeah yeah no it
was always needs to be higher right now
Chester is like Oh in between takes like
bring bring it back up every step yep
every Wow immature Tech's they'd be like
more we need more energy we need up up
more energy it literally it was
ridiculous have you ever seen it I don't
know if you ever seen these things but
it's they're almost famous for being so
ridiculously energetically it's I'll
give you a little taste it's like like
hey you have one with all the info and
all things did these two hundred sixty
five days a year
I'm Chester like that that you know and
good and you got to maintain that that's
yeah that's like I'm walking a tight
wire yeah I would warn I would always
warn the actors too that's wrapped
around your testicles exactly that's
what it felt like
but it was you know it could be jarring
for the person you're interviewing so I
just think remember like like I would
had interviews that guy from at one
point I was like hey I'm I'm about to
get really energetic learning you're not
high yeah so three years of this three
years of that three years and this is
pretty much a full-time thing at the
time uh I don't know it wasn't full-time
but it definitely supplied me you know
it was a big portion of my income it was
what I was my job I tried it one or two
a month um so yeah I was I was basically
the main host for you know those three
years so you're saying it's starting in
2006 ish yeah 2006-2007 ish to you yeah
yeah 2006 2009 yep okay and it at what
point in that process because it sounds
like you characterized it in a way now
that you you burned out at some point is
that what happened you're like I can't
okay so he's any more of this well this
is this is sore your voice just couldn't
stay that high I I think it was a few
things I I think it was honestly a part
of it was my body I am this is so silly
when your body called up with your head
well I in 2009 my body finally got over
the head but I I got obsessed with just
with lifting and I blew up to a good one
spider I was like a hundred so if I want
an 80 pound I'm not you know the biggest
guy height wise so that's that was
pretty big but it was you know I was I
was a gym jerk you know jerks not the
right word yeah I'm trying you know you
know I'm getting yeah that guy for a
period of time really really loved
working out so and I so I blew up and I
remember them you know it was like two
or three in a row like they you could I
could tell they're getting kind of upset
because they put me only put me in
triple XL shirts because you can
b-but you can't be a man you can be a
fifteen-year-old you can't be sure you
know you can't yeah you can't be exactly
and I didn't want to last ones I did was
the cruise and they're like it had to
put me in a wetsuit so they put me in a
literally triple XL so because you know
those things must be tight and fitting
like baggy looking that suit and they're
not but they're not talking you about
this they're just handing you clothes
and you're kind of reading between the
lines yeah and and then I stopped
getting calls for more what does get
exam but yeah it's - Buffy all buffed us
a lot a certain point to Disney yeah
yeah I think that was the case but you
didn't but you wanted to move on or you
wanted to just be yeah honestly I don't
really enjoy hosting I enjoy I enjoy
acting in roles that I you know certain
role that love I love acting in I love
music but hosting for me was it was a
job and yeah you're right I mean after
three years of doing it he's like okay I
got it should find something else to be
doing here you try you try to be a
musician at the same time like I get to
my attraction at that time at the time I
was doing more songwriting actually you
know it's you know David Choi right yeah
so David a diner David before YouTube
and how did you know him because of
songwriting he was he was a writer
producer for Warner travel publishing
and I at the time was was working with
some A&R over at Warner Brothers and
they paired us up and what what does
that mean exactly
Warner Music Publishing's you just said
Warner Chappell as a publishing company
a music publishing company and so you
know they they have the rights to tons
of music and he was signed to that
company to write and produce songs for
for other from other artists and whatnot
yeah yeah yeah so so we've heard we got
together me we're a writing team for a
little while and just Co wrote a bunch
of songs and while we're doing that
that's when he showed me as YouTube
channel hmm and he was like I remember
he might have even been talked to him he
was definitely up there he's definitely
high in the ranks says David Roy had a
written you saw the YouTube song yeah
the catapult ran away Cap'n
yeah yeah you know we were doing our
live broadcast on Ustream every Thursday
night got the rhett and Link cast and we
had a volunteer who would work via Skype
her name is I can't remember her name it
this particular moment but I'll remember
it in a second it'll be too late not
Stephanie it was the other girl oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah but anyway she said
unique you should get guest on your show
and we were okay we'll try that and you
should get David Choi we're like who's
that well YouTube song so then we that's
how we met David Chiu is that this was
2007 he performed the YouTube song live
on our show remember that yeah we did
that live show for almost two years
straight it's great it's like way back
then part of the rhythm like you guys oh
yeah the part of the original crew which
which I love I loved by the way that I'm
now I wasn't on the I wasn't excelling
in the YouTube platform in 2007 I was
you know much smaller in the ranks and
anything but but I was there and I was
watching Dax lame and I was in and I was
uploading it and I loved that I was
there because a lot of the the you know
the original YouTube crew is still doing
their thing it's just kind of cool to
see what some I won't say a lot but I'll
say a some of some of the original
people are still around yeah a lot of
people have fallen off but yeah I wish
wine Conan was still like oh yeah you're
going back first generation like this
first David Choi was one of those people
yeah right because she was even a
earlier than then we were definitely
so does that timeout with it when you
were riding together he was he was
moving up the ranks of YouTube in 2006
is when you're talking about 2000 I
think we met in 2006-2007 ask around
there so but yeah and that's what date
that's what got me on YouTube was David
David yeah sort of YouTube channel and
get put your music out there and then
see how Anna you get some feedback and
how's that that's super cool and then it
turned into what is today and so what
and what was that process like like what
was uh
you know first video first video was
David holding my laptop you know
basically babying me through this
showing me what to do movie HD
it was the editor and I don't know if
you members know this about David but
David was kind of known for putting way
too many effects in all his videos yeah
yeah movie hd what can you add in there
now snow lightning you know all those
the 20 effects that they had and so he
would he hailed my laptop and recorded
with a little I you know camera and
shaky and I sang one of my songs called
goddamn you're beautiful and and put it
up and I was at and then I you know I
just kept doing it never stopped now we
went back and watched that video in it I
mean it there's some production into
that video it's not just a webcam video
wait now you're thinking of them your
chart probably think of the actual music
video okay so that was later later I
made a music video for it okay yeah no
no no first video I put up it is it is
coming out of an old Mac
yeah and he's holding the laptop as a
camera he's holding and trying to do
some camera over to it but it's not that
is amazing yeah yeah I miss those days
hey remember when flipped cameras were
hot like good five months oh yeah and
then it was it went it went
use your computer camera you got a use
flip you know like gotta use the canons
and now it's just right and it's over he
can so yeah we never got a flip Kon he
didn't and we scared I got involvement I
thought I was gonna buy 20 of them and
start doing really cool things with flip
cameras I talkin like put multiple flips
up everywhere like like in the matrix
like do your version of the matrix shot
yeah jump up in the air and then video
saw yes okay so David got you going with
the webcam and then what was it just a
slow grind kind of thing or did
something pop immediately how did it
work slow grind for me I don't have a
viral video I have a song got got every
beautiful continues to do pretty well
for me when I groped nice guys I wrote a
song called nice guys finish last
it's called nice guys and I had Ryan and
KevJumba rap the rap parts and that you
know that helped bring some awareness to
my channels as you know
Narayan was number two at the time
something that yeah I've been number one
nigahiga so yeah you you did you meet
them through David yeah I've met them
through dit yeah
David is a connector by the way David
connect a lot of people and I met him I
met it was it was because of a show
called funemployed or a web series
called fun of the way that Wong free
production took was doing and I played
Duke on the show and that's how I met
those guys and yeah and I did that in
the night and then the next year I did a
song called bromance with Ryan and I did
pretty well yeah I think those two are
most vital they're not on my channel
though they're on Ryan's but those I
mean I think nice guys has over 250
million on just Ryan's Channel is that
so and then you know I'm in it so that
helps but those are the only videos that
I would say went invite Robb for me has
just been consistently hang on a space
nothin when you after that first upload
you know when you're like okay I'm gonna
make a music video for youtube I'm
assuming that this wasn't like hey I'm
going to quit my day job at this point
like what would you do how about making
money at the time oh I'm making money at
the time what air what air are we
talking about
but Partnership Program like mm like
when you first got started when you were
late yeah well there's no money right
when we first started right so you're so
you're kind of you're working with David
you're co-writing so he's got a day job
at the time what he wants Apple you're
right
well he was being paid because he was
he's actually signed by Warner title
right yeah for me I was a shirtless
bartender at a Korean Club Oh
shirtless bartender yeah is that a
euphemism no that's a that's a
literalism
yeah so tell us how that works
well first you take your shirt off okay
and chef and then you serve alcoholic
beverages to people from behind a bar it
was really it was really uh usually
weird because for me yeah I mean it was
very Korean culture too it was a bi
think as a call to booking Club so the
guys the girls got free the guys all
said sit there and the guys paid again
the guy's paid again they also have to
pay for you know they bill by tables but
they'll pull like a girl over and she
has to come down and sit for them for a
certain amount of time it's kind of a
weird scenario but like I asked
yeah I don't want to use the wrong words
here there are no wrong words I just
want to understand yeah I don't really
know all I know is escort the wrong word
I don't I just maybe I'm not sure they
well what what were you were you an
escort no I stayed in the bar did you
ever have to take your pants off no no I
never had like the pants I was every
bartender shirtless the the other guy
was a yeah but you have a girl work
there but they were injured right did
you have like a bow tie on no I'm trying
I wish I did no no and I love that you
just said no the girls weren't shirtless
but it's funny how we we said that's
when you say topless guys we've been
saying shirtless shirtless you didn't
want to apply topless to you yeah so
you're a shirtless bartender but if the
women were shirtless they would be
topless yes this is true I just weren't
that's nice I just want to take a moment
to acknowledge going from hosting Disney
365 to being yes sure I mean this is
well the reason to transition well the
muscles well Brady asked you to talk
higher yeah for it was because I was
going to give the traditional acting
thing a go it was for a short period
time I I hate the way the acne mystery
is set up I do it's such there's just so
much red tape and so on so many politics
and so many things that have nothing to
do with ambition in town and it's
unfortunate but but I was a part of that
game for a while and to make sense of
being for that game you have to find a
job that opens your week up and open
your daytime up yeah so for me it opens
your chest opens your chest up opens
your heart up opens yeah there's no
shame in it there's just a lot of
fascination I mean okay so but I know
that you know you guys we've got to know
you just over the past year or so we've
we've known that you're you're more than
just a guy who makes YouTube videos I
mean you you've gotten involved in the
business of YouTube
and some of the some innovative things
that are happening so tell us a little
bit about you know beyond your you're
not just a guy who makes YouTube videos
and has some songs on the internet
you're a guy that's you know really on
the cutting edge of what's happening
with this transition in new media in
general so tell us a little bit about
how that got started yeah okay yeah so
as as the tail end of this pursuit of
acting he sort of came out I I realized
that I didn't I don't want the actual
acting career or the music career as
much as I thought I did I just love
music and I just love acting but I don't
want the career and and there's a big
difference and I think a lot of people
don't realize the difference sometimes
and I was very fortunate to have that
epiphany not too long ago and once I did
it opened up all these fun new
opportunities to be a little bit more
business savvy and look into the
business side of what's going on and
then because of what's happening on the
internet that was the really exciting
stuff because as cliche as it is you
know it is still the why about lesson
you can really you just try new things
and so as YouTube is figuring out what's
going on and you have all these
companies pop up and you know your
instinct is oh well those are such smart
businessmen that are controlling this
space and controlling these major
companies and you quickly realize
they're not nearly as smart as you would
assume they are and they're not making
the decisions that are necessarily the
right ones and it's it's almost shocking
to when you figure that out and that you
can be a player in this and you can
actually be a pioneer and once I figured
that out I just wanted to try and do
something myself
so then how did what were the specific
opportunities how did you start making
those connections into that the business
side of it well the first thing that
sort of introduced me to the business
aspect of what was going on was I ended
up starting a company with buddy cash
warm and another buddy Abdul and Eddie
and Ryan and Kevin and we were just
brainstorming different ideas how we
could take advantage of what was going
on on the internet and do something
really cool and innovative blah blah
blah fast-forward we were
made aware of the funded channels I'll
go through this quickly we reached out
to you know Justin Layne and we all came
together and created a whole-new company
and we ran the Yamaha MF Network which
was a finite row so being a part of that
was a great it was a great sort of intro
to a lot of stuff that was going on
behind the scenes and how do you
how would you characterize that Network
uh it was you know is Asian American
centric Asian American vertical for okay
for YouTube it's interesting because you
when YouTube launched all those funded
channels I think there was an
expectation that you know that formula
was gonna work thee not not that it
necessarily didn't I don't want to say
any of the channels don't work a lot of
them do but I think there was a higher
expectation for those funding channels
to be much much more successful to say
because their you know their thought
process being okay you put the celebrity
name you get the celebrity names involve
you hot you get the better production
and we can help with the viewership by
converting that viewership from the
pre-existing viewership that comes from
our YouTube community problem is going
back to what I said before about the
word quality and if it's not what people
want to view it's not what people want
to view and it doesn't matter that it
looks and feels like TV I think they
learned a lot about long-form content
and I think long-form contents gonna
have a place on this space but my
opinion is is that there's two really
really cool things that are happening
right now one is we're figuring out
long-form we're figuring out how to make
sense of it get the viewer the
viewership is like is catching up for
long form which is gonna exploit the
fact that it doesn't matter where you're
distributing and that should we should
see some ad dollars increase because of
that it only makes sense and hopefully
marketing gets involved soon if you
haven't seen anything get truly marketed
not not in the multi-million dollar
budgets than any TV show would get right
and that's a part of the formula to make
sure that's successful so you can
control that ROI television shows a spin
as much money on marketing as they will
on the act making the show oh I I knew
think about everything that absolutely
that we make on YouTube and there's no
there is
marketing it's not that there's ya know
and and I talk about this all the time
but it's it's so frustrating but also
exciting is not hopefully it'll happen
soon but imagine the day when someone
does spend the 40 million dollars that
one of those network television shows
gets on marketing and they and they put
up the billboards they put up the
advertising they put up they get into
the magazines because if that happens
all of a sudden it is legitimate for
legitimacy right yeah you've changed
perception it doesn't matter now it
doesn't matter that it's not on YouTube
I want to see what happens when you do
that I wish that YouTube would just pick
even a youtube or pick you guys and say
okay let's just let's just get some
billboards up on Sunset let's put some
real you know a real marketing came
behind behind this and let it be
distributed on YouTube what should we do
in our billboard Chester I think well
this right here the we got to make that
a household like a symbol because I logo
I love this our fused head used heads
yes okay well I think we would do the
business shake if you put me and you
doing the business handshake on
Billboard's across America I think I
could start something yeah I'm in I'm in
oh you guys need a CMO okay we're
certainly open to the hahaha young
officer how do you know a young MF it's
a it's an acronym for you offend me you
offend my father which is a Bruce Lee
right right okay and Beyond get getting
that started with those guys I know that
you've been involved with you know
speaking of long-form what's happening
with side effects oh yeah yeah that's
exciting
the that's really exciting because you
know if you know what happened with
Ausmus TV in the acquisition and
DreamWorks Jeffrey Katzenberg - I think
I think he said this publicly and I
can't remember what where it was found
but someone was telling me he'd actually
brought up side effects and he seems to
be excited about it which along with
August is a good thing and then Brian
being who Brian is if you know Brian
he's just kind of he truly is a pioneer
in the space and what he's done with
Ausmus is amazing
so yeah I think that we're in a really
interesting opportunity here to do
something that with side effects that
might not have really didn't done before
what I was saying before me now it's a
long-form narrative musical series right
well okay so it's a little tricky but
easy to explain it's a movie the first
thing is a movie it's almost two hours
of content and we are releasing it in
three acts 1 2 3 so we just released 40
the first 40 minutes of a movie now it's
going we want it to go we would it makes
most sense to be 80 series mm-hmm
television is a 30-minute type show I
think so by releasing it at 40 minutes
that's about an almost an hour's worth
of programming in the network television
world 42 is what we were able to put up
a comparable and say okay well side
effects we released it one week we got
2.1 million views well what does MTV yet
on Teen Wolf I don't think it's 2.1
million and so a lot of these network
television programs there that's from a
lot of channels that's a hit show if
they can get to 2 million yeah in a week
and so we have that direct comparable
because of the length of time that we
released it so that was again I think
there's a testament to how smart
awesomenesstv is and what they're doing
but so now we're you know we just
wrapped the rest of the movie we'll
release it again and we'll release act 2
and add 3 over the next few months but
the big picture here I think for
everyone is and we are you know where
our minds are is let's make this a real
show let's let's just supposed to make
let's make a you know how many episodes
are Nana's show like that but let's make
a Glee let's let's make the next Glee
now you show up in a lot of places I
mean you play the the older brother /
father figure basically in that story
because the dad is that that is the
story looking for the dad basically yeah
right so you show up there but then
you're you're you're behind the scenes
from a business standpoint as I don't
know if it's a partner or whatever the
word is for that but you're in you're
involved I mean what's your executive
producer ok executive producer and then
you're appearing in Camp Takota which is
coming in just as an actor that's just
as an actor there so
what's your strategy I mean it show up
in a number of places get your hand in
on the kind of the executive producing
part of it the business side of it - it
seems like how would you how would I'm
interested to know what your strategy is
how would you characterize it we haven't
even talked about what I'm actually most
excited about this okay - in this space
we'll get to that next give it - what is
it factor it in well then you'll get
then what I'm actually most excited more
than anything else is actually the music
industry and how the YouTube is gonna
play into that and I'm in the middle of
building something out for that right
now that's a lot of my time energy has
been going is I'm looking at sort of
company that revolves around yeah making
a sense of distribution for music on the
line given that radio has controlled
their business for so long and if radio
declines it's it's not really declining
at the moment but it's I think it's
inevitable that it's going to have a
decline at some point yeah you know and
whether or not that's a fast decline or
not it's you still have to accept the
fact that there's distribution channels
or there's distribution online like
YouTube where I'll give given a specific
example of boyceavenue for instance has
what for something million subscribers
they have an engine that can guarantee a
certain amount here is what I'm really
really excited about is I look at the
Miley Cyrus's and the Selena Gomez's and
the Demi Lovato's and even like even the
Katy Perry's now and a lot of those
artists no I'm not saying anything bad
about the artist but the truth is and I
know this for a fact
a lot of the songs I already heard those
songs I have my friends I have some
friends that wrote their songs I've
heard those songs with demo singers
before they even hit their ears right so
I know that we call those originals
they're not originals in my mind those
are covers Trina's covering a song let's
be honest Demi Lovato is covering a song
but they don't want they'll never say it
that way and they're gonna get the
writing quit credit with quotations and
they're gonna play that game and that's
so that the perception is there for the
kids to feel like that's oh that's her
that's Miley song like that she wrote
that that's coming from her no no
usually not now that being the case what
excites me about that is so what really
is the difference between when
deme sings a song in my opinion what I
would say is a cover of someone else's
song and the next day someone with
massive distribution decides to do their
own version of that song and releases it
there's not a big difference the fact
that they are quote unquote covering it
if they're doing it online is just
public but she went behind the scenes
grab somebody else's song and did the
same thing now now she paid for it
though she
well Nathan here's the other thing is
the record labels also spend a
six-figure amount on folks you know
radio spins right yeah also playing that
formula where okay let's just pump it
into the ears of the listeners and
there's only so much radio real estate
to be you know to be have so they're
really working off of a very specific
business model to you know make sure
that these songs are successful and it
costs a lot of money to do so that's why
distribution on the internet is so
exciting for the music industry because
it's going to democratize music
eventually eventually we are going to
have an option of these great hit songs
that are written by these amazing
songwriters that are you know give in to
Demi's but they're given to the world
and anyone should be able to create a
version that can be the version that is
most listened to I think we will soon
see scenarios where the Boise avenues
and the Taylor Wars and some of these
create musicians that have a you know
will do covers quite often you know
they're already popping on the top you
know singer/songwriter charts but it's
just getting more and more and more
because their distribution is growing
and growing growing imagine the day when
you know Demi releases that the sales
are so-so
they control their own distribution
which is a significant if out more and
they beat out those numbers now they're
sitting on top of the iTunes charts
they're finding more people then Demi
whose song is it really so is it ace is
it a specifically cover oriented thing
as opposed to original songs because
that's what you're using as your example
yeah I mean because like I wouldn't put
ed Sheeran in this conversation or maybe
another better known singer-songwriter
but you know and there are you know I'm
not discounting the fact that that
Taylor Swift and Katy Perry do write
original songs but a lot there's a
a huge amount of songs that are written
by songwriters and then behind the
scenes you know pitch to different the
deme camps in the Celina camps and one
of those girls picks it up or those
artists pick it up and they're more or
less a poster child for that yeah and is
that the best pairing is Miley Cyrus the
best person to sing whatever hit song
she sings next that was written by
somebody else
you know odds probably not is she the
best from a business standpoint maybe
with everything that's going on in her
world and a lot of people have eyes on
her but is that the way we want to pair
the singer to a song I don't think so I
think there's a better version of that
song that should be exploited and I
think we're in about to start seeing
that more and more and more which is
exciting yeah very interesting
okay so let's bring it back to your
YouTube persona for a second as you know
as we were talking about I would think
that back in the day you had all these
girlfriends now with these songs that
you put out you've got you know you've
got the young girl swooning a little bit
right you've got you you've had some
success in relationships and you have
expectations you've got stalkers stalker
girls right I think so I think I have
some soccer - soccer any evidence of
that in a creepy evidence that the
problem is I don't I really want ice one
what you guys have it's not fair I want
to settle down I want to like just marry
a stalker I want as well my wife doesn't
listen to this
Kristy is I was not a stalker but if she
would have been and I think I was the
stalker
oh I stalk my wife on that yeah but uh
so you haven't had any weird run-ins
with fans no not really
when I had a peel box I had a few weird
things said to me but like what I always
resort to this one thing that always I
always remember envelope full of dirt
and in tax
tax like them yeah yeah dirt and tact
yeah with no explanation either in a box
full of Star Trek old VHS Star Trek
tapes were they good I didn't watch them
but I'm assuming they were third that
they were probably dubbed over dude you
got to watch them what is this okay so
maybe not with any of these females but
with you have had success you said
you're single right now yeah I'm saying
right now but you were dating Taryn for
a while right yeah so let's talk about
that when did you know you mean dating
another internet personality I think
that that's there haven't been a lot of
relationships where there was each
person had a public persona yeah and
what were their personal life was that a
marketing decision yeah business is good
no I come I love Taryn and I still loved
her I think she's just she's like a
wonderful human when you have to play
her romantic interest and side effects
yeah yeah although she dumped me in in
life and in movie so okay yeah you and
you so you were like she was like
breaking up with you and you were like
wait wait wait is this is this on script
yeah now it just didn't work out and but
let's let's start with how you how long
did you guys date I don't know we had
that rocky ending where you you know you
go off and on and off and on and I
probably yeah I mean I'm I have a lot to
I'm a big part of why that didn't work
out anyway our point of reference is the
VidCon performance yeah yeah we are so
you what was the name of the song you
were performing who am I to stand in
your way
Who am I to stand in your way and you
gave this introduction I was like wow
this is hold on this is going somewhere
I'm kind of perking up I'm listening
it was kind of a heartfelt introduction
to this song about a girl you had lost
you didn't you didn't mention anyone
yeah I assumed this was Tara yeah
talking about her and and then it was
you started breaking up yeah is this you
know okay someone okay its Chester a
master performer
yeah or is he crying up there yeah I was
a little bit of crying up there okay I
was sitting next to my wife and I had to
monitor my wife at that moment went in
the middle of you singing this so no I
look over there and my wife is like
fixated you know it was a good-looking
guys got a great voice break um on now
what was going on don't tell me what was
going on up there uh you know she I
hadn't seen her in so long she was there
not in listening not listening not there
there but at VidCon and I bumped into
her for the first time in a while and I
ever since the break-up basically I'm a
baby and I'm trying to deal with a
breakup in certain different ways and I
mean trying okay maybe maybe we won't
talk at all let's do that and see if
that helps
it's all me the issues tres way she's
great but the I got to get Taryn this
and she's she really like you was very
good at being there for me I in the
break I was if that makes any sense like
she's very she's one of most rational
people I know and I like to pride myself
on being rational too but was you know
it was she helped make that as easy as
possible so if I was like I can talk to
you for a while cuz it's too hard you
know she no respected that and or if I
need to talk to her she found out too
but again obviously I'm on I'm the baby
in this breakup for sure yeah so it
fueled I'm sure now though if I am cured
I am I I am a 100% good I'm good and
it's all it's because I it's because
that crush thing I said earlier so you
write songs about a new personnel yeah I
already wrote a song about this new
person yeah
what's her name Stephanie standing no I
can't say she sent me some starters yeah
but okay you can't say her name but have
you released a song yet that it was
about her yeah no here's the thing
nothing's gonna happen with this girl
nothing's gonna happen it it was just
not unless you tell us who she is and we
can help you out yeah yeah yeah it's not
all this there's a there's very concrete
there's there's a lot there's a lot of
reasons why this will network which is
fine just go for it anyway if she's got
a husband you know yeah yeah but the
point is this though the point is this I
don't even care I mean I I would love a
snare this girl is so cool she's so cool
no she's amazing she's awesome
but the fact that I actually could even
feel something like that again you know
I can be aware of people being cool but
to actually have a feeling me like oh my
god you're making me feel that thing
that is never explained properly by
anyone yeah that was the first time
since Taryn and even though nothing will
happen with this girl was just nice to
what does feel like I have to know why
you're saying nothing will happen is she
married
no she's not married but she's in a
relationship I can't talk with somebody
else yeah um you you both know her oh
I'm so bad I'm really good at like
pushing people to talk about things but
I'm so I I wouldn't see it but you but
here's thing and this is where it's this
is where it's great
Wow okay I get to be let's ask yes or no
questions let's play that game oh I
cannot leak because is she I can't I
can't
but she's taller than you know this is
like the guest
so she's rare glasses she's shorter than
you if I can't give out any more details
because you know her and it says when I
don't want her to know I I really want
this to to wash over and get back to her
content with friends and and be happy
that we're friends and again I'm just
excited that my I felt something again
he says I sound like a she's not a do
okay yes so there's okay even if it's
not about her it's about your feelings
for her yeah no no it's it's it's this
out yes yeah yeah I'm a little like hot
it sucks there's nothing more will
happen however the fact that I could
even get there cuz after Taryn I was for
the longest time I was just kind of like
there's an I was I was like nothing I
wanted her I just want to go back and
ischium man if you're gonna keep being
this way yeah yeah I'm never gonna speak
to you again
say said we're gonna have one of those
relationships where we can't talk
anymore because I'm being so unless you
wanna date guys but the interesting the
interesting thing is that you have you
know you use the break-up that it fueled
your creativity you know you wrote an
amazing song about it I think we ate
okay eight amazing songs
seven or eight songs yeah is that how
you I mean and now you're writing a song
about this new crush so do you ever
write a song that isn't true you know
it's just like yes but I don't like
those nearly as much as those take
longer to write those are from writing
sessions with guys and repeating people
whoever writers and and those are a
little more contrived and you can feel
it usually the songs that come from
something you know and you can pump
those least can pump those out mm-hm it
kind of just spill onto the page and
done so yes I do write songs that are
not about something but I didn't of my
music is is all from real things yeah
hmm and what's uh what's what's next
what's what's on the horizon I know
you've got that you've got
by the time misses out camp Takota will
have been released to the world oh yeah
I'm I'm in that I'm in my boxers for a
lot of that know most of my screen time
is in my boxers in that venes I'm really
really good friends with Chris right now
and Nick right out there I've known the
middle school oh really
I've known them yeah I know them since
seventh grade even though Chris always
says six and I get really upset like I
didn't know you in sixth grade in any
way every single time like you can't
remember no tape on the inside of the
boxers to make sure that it like the
hole doesn't open up no funny you know
what I love about being a little older
you did this happen for you guys to like
oh no I hope I never get seen naked and
then it really is that like old man
Locker mentality I just don't care I
really like oh if something flap opened
up it would be funny to me it would be
embarrassing for the person but I would
be like that's my penis yeah somewhere
recently that happened I was like it is
an old guy thing guys don't carry your
shame yeah yeah you do you just forget
about I suppose a question oh what's
coming up next yeah and you know more
side effects and then what about
producing a movie actually obviously
moving in the next few months we're
gonna get started I can't I don't know
if I'm allowed to say the director is
yet so I won't just in case is he taller
than you you know him are you dating him
yeah crush do you have a crush on he's
such a great guy
and no yeah I know and but the movies
the movies really really cool lose
really cool and it's I think of it as
you know this is the end for the YouTube
community and I'm very cool I'm we got a
pretty good budget and you know a lot of
those a lot of the same you know cash is
involved and Mark styling John Strauss
are involved those guys wrote something
about Mary and again I don't know how if
I can list the other players but I'm
sure we'll have an announcement in the
next month or two okay and we're talking
YouTube's release here or like you know
I think this is it's kind of the same
thing that we're doing this with side
effects or camp Takota
with the demon you know you make a good
looking feature film and then you played
the distribution game afterwards you
figure out you know yeah there's
opportunity don't have to you don't have
to have a distribution plan necessarily
you know before you finish the movie
mm-hmm because there will be
opportunities right right well we're
excited to see that and everything else
that's coming down the pike
yeah and let us know when miss standin
reaches out to you yeah we want to hear
from you we're gonna triple date let's
do it and there you see it
our I tried to make a pun about it with
his last name but then I realized that
you're not seeing anything you're just
hearing that you're biscuit with Chester
see Lionel as I'm gonna call him from
now on yeah you know what a missed
opportunity you know if my middle name
is Lila you better believe it that would
be what I would be going by I seriously
considered naming one of my children
Lionel because it starts with an L and
that's what we did with our children we
name them without names this is
interesting that I mean Lando is a great
name but was it you that made that
decision or is it your wife that was
like no Lionel's we're not gonna do that
or were you just like oh it just seems
too jokey alright well I preferred Lando
you preferred well don't tell Lionel
that we're never gonna get Lionel on
this thing if you tell him that you
prefer to land up to Lionel that's true
you should probably retract that
immediately sir would you like to
retract that yes I would like to retract
that I I do I do have to say that you
know I had to point out to pull you back
today I had to pull you back from you
were really really pushing really
pushing to get him to confess his crush
I think it made him feel uncomfortable I
think you might have to you might have
to call him and apologize I'm willing to
do that I mean I didn't he I guess when
you've been married for 13 years you
lose a sensitivity oh you got a crush on
boy now if you tell me - yeah - this
whole crush thing I mean it's like what
if you like somebody just say it you
know what get
if you wanna you know what I'm so far
removed from that that I just think it's
just it's just fun it's just in is it
was just in good honest fun I wasn't
trying to push him I just thought it was
fun and I maybe I should have been a
little more sensitive I what I'm saying
is that did I push him too far I'm just
saying a crush thing brought it well
well okay he seemed to want my takes it
out of him no no okay okay so that's the
thing I guess that's the question that I
beneath the question is did you really
think like what did you think the
chances because like when I'm observing
this happen and I know that there's a
zero percent chance that he's gonna give
it up so but in your mind are you
thinking oh I'm just having fun I'll see
where this goes I know he's not gonna
tell me who is crushes on or do you
really think that there's a chance that
he's gonna just break down and tell you
what motivates you in that moment I'm
one I'm having fun too
I feel like I what I'm having fun too
I feel like I owe it to your biscuit
listeners to try as hard as I can
if someone says well I will say things
exchanged because I do have a crush now
dot dot dot I I owe it to the listeners
rat to to see the biscuit ears to see
what the dot dot dots can reveal hey I
agree with that and you should I believe
that you should have asked him twice you
asked him I don't know I'm gonna go back
to the eight to nine eight to ten times
maybe a dozen so I just ate at one point
I was like okay he's obviously not gonna
go there you know we pushed him and and
then I feel like I had to pull you back
and it was like you know pulling back a
dog a drug dog dog that's found the
drugs like no no no it's cool we know
that they're in there
we're gonna take care of it now we're
not gonna we're gonna give you your
little reward but you know you don't get
to actually get the drugs in your mouth
Chester Lionel see I'm sorry for pushing
you so hard I mean I actually apologized
to him once we stopped recording
I said amen you know I hope you'll
forgive me forgive me I didn't speak
English first of all I said I hope
you'll forgive me for making you squirm
a little bit but
[Music]
and I don't remember what I said I'm
sorry I wouldn't know it's a moment it's
all in good fun now you've made it
public what I had fun too I know okay
well we're still friends
he didn't leave upset no he didn't he he
hug this hug this both I'm a little
upset he I don't know who is crushes
yeah well I'm freaking upset well I know
who it is who is it I'm gonna keep it to
myself you think you know who didn't
know when when he hugged me at the end
he was pretty doom I know you think you
know who do you think it is right I'm
not gonna say you cannot in your night
you can ask me 12 times and I'm still I
gotta tell you are they taller than you
taller than me
is she taller than you yet she is
because woman 2 6 8 what if he would
have said no I'm not gonna tell him who
it is but she's taller than rest all
right guys thanks for listening to this
ear biscuit we're in this together and
we do this every week I don't care what
year it is
I resolve to be here for you and to do
these until we stop doing it and for
those of you who are listening you're
gonna leave before I leave is all I'm
gonna say
and for those of you who are listening
in the distant future the year 3003
almost a whole millennium from now Wow
just in case that happens just in case
you're in the year 3000 and 3 and you're
listening to this it's like wow don't we
sound weird hello
hey this is what we always like you sure
people this is what English sounded like
and we're glad that you're that you
listen to me that is what this is I mean
like we said it beginning the inception
of this was it's a time capsule of these
interesting people from the internet at
this particularly interesting point in
entertainment it's encapsulated for the
people of 3003 yeah because the world
ends at 3,000 for everybody knows that
[Music]
[Music]